[Music]
yo welcome back to arthur record where
we talk about
whatever we want okay we got timmy back
i missed you guys it's been like six
months dude yeah i know
has it been like i [ __ ] thought that
he came to jk news or something i'm just
going crazy here
nah i haven't seen you guys since 2020
like the end of 2020. it's cause you
keep popping up on my feet and [ __ ]
that's why bro i feel like i see you all
the time
yeah i mean you know that's how we keep
up with each other's lives you know what
i'm saying scrolling and liking
but i'm glad to get some some real life
i know for real how do you like the
[ __ ] dad life man that's crazy
i'm not gonna lie yeah it's lit it is
that's the time yeah when you got a good
kid it's lit yeah but you know what i i
had to
i had to write i texted bart and geo a
personal
apology you did yeah you i don't know
you didn't reply jio replied but
[ __ ] up like
a couple years ago it was either
it was either end game or infinity war
like i was giving you all a hard time
because it was like six months later and
you hadn't seen it i'm like bruh
how have you not seen like end games
that's valid
and he was like they're like we have a
kid i'm like brah
it's been six months and he was still
trying to be like no don't tell me what
happens yep i was there for that yeah so
i was like come on bro but
what happens at a good fellas
titanic oh you ruined it oh but spoiler
alert
but now since i have a baby even like
all the new movies are [ __ ] streaming
on hbo max and i still
don't have time like it took me like
when snyder cut came out
dawg it took me a whole week to get
through that [ __ ] because i'd watch like
well that [ __ ] is [ __ ] long i know
but still
it takes anyone a whole week but it was
great
what happens like is there like
mad crying and you just have to keep
holding the baby or like what happens
where you have no time
yeah because it's like something needs
constant attention
yeah and like especially if once they
start moving
around they could fall off the couch
they could cry they could be hungry
diaper needs to be changed so it's just
constant
so like we would watch game of thrones
and an episode we would watch in like
five or six ten minute segments exactly
to finish but the way that you set that
up
and then you talk about you guys talk
about the joy in your life
that makes me not want to get a kid the
evidence sucks
stack the pros and cons it sucks no but
it's great
it's no it's it gets better and better
it's it's super fun
just because i was telling steve that
like everything is so
new right so it's like every small
development
is lit like the first time like she
farted i was like
and i was just like and now she farts
all the time and it's so funny
and i was telling steve that like you
know babies don't even smile
for like two months so i'm like trying
to be funny and [ __ ] and she's just like
drool oh my god and so she finally
smiled i was like
yeah i'm the funniest person she looks
like you man it's
crazy i don't see cheetah what the [ __ ]
you know those were all the comments and
at first i was like guys like i just i
look like babies i have a small like i
rounded it
i look like a baby i have like [ __ ] a
fat round head all babies look like me
but then as time went on i was like oh
[ __ ] yeah
they also get more un-asian
un-asian yeah they start off super easy
when i got
taika right this will look like this
looks like yeah that's
true it looked like geo had nothing to
do with them yeah i
said that yeah i mean like these are
strong pull it out and it's like oh what
the [ __ ] what happened
and then later on they get more and more
or like they they the mom
starts coming in it's weird yeah i don't
think the mom's coming
honestly after that haircut though he
looks pretty mexican now you don't see
geo in tiger at all
no at all yeah a little bit short in the
lips and stuff but no
we're not the inner the inner face in
the cheeks it's a 90
bart situation but the body in the head
is bart
but he's stretching out though he he's
kind of getting along like like geo like
that's helping yeah that's helpful yeah
yeah tiger looks like a grown ass man
now
yeah kind of this is a teenager
he's like eight years old and [ __ ] how's
her kid now she
is like a little over three weeks now
wow
that's crazy man first giggle the other
day i'm like
man this is tight because at first it
was just like
did you hear that did you hear that i'm
hilarious
um and she's just beginning to like you
see a little bit of chia
like in the lips and like kind of the
eyes here and there but
yeah man it's [ __ ] fun she is going
to come in way more
yeah you know what i was like you're
like i hope so
everyone's kind of everyone's kind of
like hey it looks like tim was like
sorry guys
trying to disappoint you
but it's fun man um you know i never
changed the diaper until
like we had the baby and now but then
now i didn't grow up around kids yeah me
neither you didn't have any
uh like nephews or nieces or anything
like that no i was the youngest
like in the cousin group and then um i
was the only child so i never
like just had any experience with babies
and now i'm like [ __ ] diaper
expert bro take me into the first night
you get home you're on your own for the
first time door closes nobody's there
but you and she and the baby first night
me and she and the baby and it's like
it's weird because they sleep so much
but it's hard to get them to sleep
you know what i'm saying so first night
um i was staying up
we were in the hospital for like three
days while she was recuperating
and then um that's the worst experience
too right because they keep coming in
every two hours to check up on something
yeah so like so many nurses come in they
can't even sleep
yeah like it's literally like three days
of no sleep they keep coming in you're
like [ __ ]
you're like i gotta take this
temperature guy do this yeah they gotta
do all these different things they close
the door
extra hard you're not buying it you're
not buying the tests they're taking
about
no i bought them all at all
this guy's skeptical [ __ ] and so you
gotta you you it's like it's just
you're trying to figure everything out
right so it's like and i want chia to
sleep so i'm like trying to rock the
baby
for sure that's like the sleepiest week
is like that's that's the first couple
days where i just you know
neither of us really slept at all and um
that's like there's one picture i posted
on instagram but it's like the middle of
the day and i'm holding the baby i'm
like
and that was real that wasn't a fake
picture you know we just knocked out
and you're taking the picture
[Laughter]
but yeah man it's just a lot of like you
know you're just trying to everyone says
you know make sure you say goodbye to
sleep you know that's the worst part and
it was like
it's facts like first first month or two
was kind of a struggle but now
she's getting like a solid like six to
eight hours
which is late the first week you're like
how do people have five of these things
yeah for real but she wants like three
more so
really yeah you guys getting started on
that yeah yeah
you know what we're going to let the
baby be a baby for a couple more months
and then um once once start to get
coming again
once how's that once the baby can
actually kind of like at least like hold
her head up and [ __ ] we'll take maybe
go like hawaii for a trip and then and
we might start trying again
damn three weeks for some reason i
thought like
[ __ ] was a few months no three months oh
well you said three weeks
i did you did say i was scratching my
head for a little bit just like three
weeks ago
he said three weeks all right
months yeah three months
how old is chia chia is
third no twenty found
she's 20 something very nicely handled
yeah
she's she's 32. they like to keep track
of dates yeah wow
man i don't think guys can remember [ __ ]
though like
you could be with this person all your
life and you're like she's like 50 and
you're like she's like 29. well because
i know that she's three years younger
than me and i'm so used to lying about
my age that's what i
have to do okay good very nice fairness
yeah that's facts though
have you seen parts of your parents that
you've never seen before
yeah so what's funny is like you know so
we used to try and get dinner at my
family like every week right
and i love my parents but you know how
it is you visit your parents and
sometimes it's like all right
after like an hour and a half it's like
okay enough i gotta i heard that story
so many [ __ ] times i'm leaving like i
gotta get out of here man
and um you know it's like i visit my mom
of course my mom has like a week's worth
of just like
nag that she wants to get out
now bro dinner with the family is my
mom's [ __ ] playing with the baby the
whole time
she cooks goes plays with the baby and
then me and my dad are just chilling
having a beer my dad's like oh thank god
you're selling a baby really well right
now all right that's better yeah
maybe all she needed was some like baby
to not get her to focus on complaining
yeah just recycle that energy into
something else [ __ ] that sounds
amazing damn so that is the answer
to just chilling moms out it's like
babies
yeah because normally i'm there like yes
mom i know i know
yes now they got something else to deal
with argue about
you know what it's funny because like go
find something dude i was always i was
like a good kid so it's like
my mom to this day the [ __ ] my mom nags
me about is like
are you eating the fruit that i gave
it's like stop giving me so much [ __ ]
fruit i'm like
it's like little boxes of mangoes you
know i'm saying i'm like mom yes we eat
the fruit
today's video is brought to you by hbo
max and i gotta give a big great thank
you for hbo max
for giving some love to the asian
american community
because they want to recognize and also
celebrate
that you know our community is
not so much getting great representation
but they want to put
a lot of the content that our culture
has to offer on their platforms so we
got a lot of awesome things like
warrior you guys know that one it was
made by
bruce lee himself it was a script that
he had hidden inside the garage and then
they found it and they went and then
they [ __ ] brushed up all the dust and
they read it and they're like this is an
awesome show we gotta get this made and
i personally
was uh invited to the screening and i
and i got to see it before it came out
that's dope dude
and it's something where i'm like yo
finally
there's something like this we always
wanted to make something that was
a timepiece in the gold rush era yes in
california
and and it's a mix of you know chinese
american history and everything
and i think it was badass and they have
all kinds of other stories and shows too
like studio ghibli mortal kombat house
of hoe
the super ball and asians so they have
all these shows so you can go check it
out
see stories made by asian americans
celebrate aapi month
make sure you go to link below and sign
up for hbo max now and you can start
streaming all these shows
and it's like [ __ ] like that you know
but but now what they're coming at me
with is like
now mind you they haven't had a baby in
like [ __ ] like 30 plus years right
so they see the new [ __ ] me and cheer
doing like in the vlogs and stuff like
we have like the snoo
where you like it's like this thing
where it's a it's a thing where you put
your baby to sleep and it
pays attention to the babies like noises
and signals and it'll like rock it
oh according to the reactions that the
babies are doing and you're [ __ ] auto
bearers
yeah pretty much so and then so you put
the baby into this thing where you put
your hits
or her arms down and it straps her in
and then like a straight jacket
yeah pretty much but like they say that
babies like being tight like that
because it reminds them of the womb they
have to get swaddled yeah yeah you don't
have to get swatted it's like an auto
swaddle
so my parents are like you shouldn't be
doing that
the baby feels like suffocated in there
how would they know i know
yeah so my parents are like are you sure
you shouldn't be
you should you should let her arms out
i'm like you guys
you don't know it's been [ __ ] 40
years for you you know like just
let us do our thing for some new stuff
there's some new stuff that's their way
of saying
back in my day yeah so they don't know
how to actually work so that's the new
stuff they're coming at me with
um and we just kind of have to remind
them like hey man you guys are old just
be
grandparents have fun so
i mean did it back in the day they had a
[ __ ] straight up burlap sack that
they put over their shoulder and [ __ ]
like you ever see those
old pictures of people in the village
they just had a baby and a sack and the
mom is just holding it like a
[ __ ] like a big purse you know what
are you doing
well you don't see in those villages is
the nurse is coming in every two hours
checking the temperature
and then the kids getting polio or some
[ __ ]
yeah he still
that's the cool thing about my dad he's
pretty like um
i guess like progressive because he was
like
i'd ask him like hey do you have any
advice about raising kids and stuff like
that he was like honestly
information improves all the time so he
goes whatever i know
is not going to be as good whatever you
know you guys look [ __ ] up on youtube
and like whatever online
he's like you just do whatever you think
is best that's your kid and i'm just
gonna watch
from the side if you need support i'll
be there for you but my mom's like your
mom where she's like
watching the vlogs and she'll text me
from taiwan [ __ ] like
[ __ ] tips and stuff like that there
was literally an instance where cuz like
baby's tongue can get they get white
from the breast milk and [ __ ] like that
so it's like and it can be a situation
called thrush where it turns into a
fungus and it affects like the mom's
nipple all types of [ __ ] right
but or it could also just be like white
[ __ ] on the tongue you know what i'm
saying yeah
and so we went to the we asked the
pediatrician this is an issue people
just like nah i'll go away in a few
months when she starts eating real food
and getting more saliva
and i told my parents because my parents
were like you should be doing something
like watching it or something right
but nah we went to the pediatrician she
said it was cool and my dad was like no
no they're wrong
[Laughter]
my parents are like no don't no you
should be doing something about it i'm
like guys
just just play with the baby do you
think they were
super um helicopter parents with you
like extra careful yeah you can kind of
see
like wait were there were they like
super careful with you and [ __ ] i mean i
you know i was there only one
and you know they're first and only so
like it's possible yeah
um or they don't trust your child
raising abilities
maybe they still think they're raising
you yeah i think i think
now that my kid has a kid my mom's like
that
really yeah my mom would be like trying
to give me like driving advice [ __ ]
jacket advice
i'm like [ __ ] i got it like like all
the weather cold weather
oh i see it [ __ ] like dumb
these are pockets here dumb as [ __ ] or
what you know my mom lectured me the
other day
she's like you shouldn't be doing all
these young people sports because you're
old now that's so easy
because your body that's such a mom
thing to say though is much weaker than
it used to be
and you're completely gonna injure
yourself and she goes and i see you
snowboarding
and i know you're just trying to relive
your childhood but you need to stop
because you're old
she's getting deep with it she's like so
i'm like thanks for the support mom she
goes but is it fun though and i'm like
it's [ __ ] fun
she wants to try it like after you
[ __ ] depress me and call me a loser
she goes well just don't get injured
okay i don't want you to get hurt
because you don't heal as fast cause
you're so
old jesus christ this is why
i don't have to deal with any of that
[ __ ] because i just don't talk to my mom
but she was just roasting me you know
like it was it was light-hearted it was
but it was just she was going in dude
like she talked [ __ ] so
good like don't you feel bad we're not
talking to your mom i tried not to i do
talk about them but
i feel like yeah i just always it's like
whenever it's the day that i'm gonna
probably call my mom
i'm always like yeah i gotta be ready
yeah because you know she's gonna start
lecturing you no not not lecturing me
it's but tell you the lamest [ __ ] well
no she lives
she lives in a category 5 hurricane
basically
she's the ultimate warrior warriors
i gotta be on the phone with her and
just hear about how everything is
getting destroyed around here
solid stuff oh nothing that much with me
no
she she makes me feel like [ __ ] cuz she
talks to her parents every night well i
mean
and they're in canada too so you know
she kind of feels like she's got a real
conversation
real conversations though every day you
know what i'm saying and i'm like she's
like
and my mom calls and i'm like ask my mom
call me
i'll talk to her later i'll i'll talk to
them
on in the line app i'm at the park i go
i text her i'm filming right now
and she's like she's like she was like i
would feel so bad if i if my kids didn't
want to talk to me i'm like oh
don't annoy them so i'm like
what i'm like i see them every week
that's enough you know
but at least my dad jokes about it like
i went to go see him
and i go like ding dong and he opens the
door and goes who are you
that's right i started laughing i was i
don't know who you i haven't talked to
in months
and then he likes he'll make like a joke
out of it but all the stuff that my mom
texts me the only reply i could only say
is
okay you know be like did you know that
in uh the high school next to my house
someone caught covet so they shut the
high school down i'm like that's so
funny okay
yeah what is there to add yeah i don't
know i don't know what to do
right like what you mean okay you don't
oh my care oh no poor high school
what do you want me to do yeah i'm at
poor high school oh
i know my son loved me oh she wanted
though that's all she wanted
but i don't even know what to say most
of them are just like oh you know
peaches on sale in taiwan i'm like
okay do you ever fear that you might you
might do end up doing that to taika
yourself
he's already doing it now he's already
doing it bro my parents
i tell you what my parents take it next
level random because they have no
perception of like how to text really
yeah so it's like but they text all the
time yeah i'm saying so my dad the other
day for example
sent a screenshot of of chio lifting
weights
of your wife lifting weights from
instagram
that's advanced that he knows that into
our into our little family group chat
yeah and i was like
dad no one cares about geo working out
what is this what was the context no and
then this is his reply
house veda
[Laughter]
completely ignored everything so he
sends
you a picture of geo worker oh jio
working out
into the group chat with the family and
i'm like
dad what is this no one cares about this
and he's like
how's the baby he's like oh [ __ ] i gotta
change the subject
to the day we never talked about it i
never asked him
like is he is he trying to say like look
she's she's killing it or like
she shouldn't be doing that or like
there's no point to it no one knows
oh wrong group sorry
[Laughter]
that's what it was that's why you
changed the subject he changed
he's a part of the [ __ ] uh of the
reddit
oh my god
let us know when he starts sending deep
fakes
oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] hilarious dude
yeah but i was like i don't i don't know
what this is man
i i i wonder if yeah if you guys are
gonna be annoying
dads that the kids are like [ __ ] i can't
wait to get to get away from these
[ __ ]
because you know every kid thinks their
dad is lame even the cool dads and then
the but the friends are like oh dad
your dad's [ __ ] hilarious what's your
deal yeah and they hate them even more
they're like [ __ ] you they like you more
than me if even dave chappelle's son is
like
dad you're lame where's kevin hart at
they're like
no dads have a chance dude that's facts
yeah even like the rock stars being like
oh my god dad you're so crying
don't count please let me know all
[Laughter]
like jason momoa's like whoever his kids
are that's going to be a doozy
yeah because there comes a flip right
when the kid thinks that dad is the
coolest
ever and then they're always at school
like my dad does this [ __ ]
and then they like [ __ ] defend them
and then there's that flip where it's
like man dad you're [ __ ] lame dude
and the flip happens like a year after
the first one
you go from being like my dad's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then you just meet
enough people and you're like oh no
we're in the middle of the road there's
this comedian i forget who it was but
uh he was like you know he's like here's
my tip for you when when you have a son
show him your penis when he's like five
years old
and for the rest of his life he's gonna
say my dad had the biggest dick
in the whole world that's solid
kill off his friends for the rest of his
life my dad's dick is huge
especially if they're like looking up at
the dick wow
[Music]
you